a Republican wonders whether colored
people his word colored people get
coronavirus more because they don't know
or refuse to wash their hands in other
words are dirty immigrants more likely
to get coronavirus and they happen to be
the colored ones this is the question
from a guy who should never show his
face in public again his name is Steve
Hoffman he's a Republican state senator
in Ohio didn't really have to tell you
he was a Republican as some of you know
coronavirus is disproportionately
hitting the non-white population of the
United States there are different
reasons why some of our non-white
populations in the US have more
underlying health conditions that can be
linked to poverty often poverty brings
with it poor health pre-existing
conditions appear to D predispose people
to more serious cases of coronavirus you
then also have to account for sometimes
having in access to inferior medical
services there's a lot of different
factors here but the point is we know
that minorities including black
Americans are being disproportionately
hit by coronavirus during a hearing
about racism Ohio State Senator Steve
Hoffman asked is it possible that the
black and colored population might be
getting hit harder by coronavirus
because they don't wash their hands as
well as white people essentially
proposing the idea that these folks are
dirtier they're not washing their hands
as well or as frequently now get ready
for this Huffman is a doctor he said
quote my point is I understand African
Americans have a higher incidence of
chronic conditions and it makes them
more susceptible to death from Kovich
but why it doesn't make them more
susceptible to just get kovat could it
just be that African Americans or the
colored population do not wash their
hands as well as other groups or wear a
mask or do not socially distance
themselves that could be the explanation
of the higher incidence now Ohio
Commissioner on mine or the Ohio
Commission
on minority health director Angela
Dawson said what Huffman is asserting is
not the opinion of leading medical
experts in this country that probably
doesn't come as a surprise to you
so either the implication as black
people don't wash their hands correctly
because they don't know how or black
people don't wash their hands correctly
because they're dirty and they don't
care to wash their hands pick your
explanation as to what Steve Huffman is
saying here and then of course you know
this reference to the colored population
like what year are we in again and for
me this is more proof that we need more
people from younger generations who it
would never even occur to to use this
language in these positions of power and
it's also a reminder that just because
you're a doctor doesn't mean you're
necessarily smart look at some of the
things Ben Carson believes if you need
proof of that now one last thing let's
for a second take seriously the question
of are there hand-washing differences
among populations because this has been
studied we're linking to one such study
and the conclusions from this study were
that women tend to wash their hands more
and better in other words using soap and
scrubbing long enough women are better
hand washers than men and non-white
people are better hand washers than
white people when this has been studied
disproportionately white men are the
worst offenders when it comes to
bathroom hand washing we're linking to
this study in the description to the
YouTube video for this story certainly
something to think about this guy should
never show his face in public again